Tesla is making a bet that an enormous
five billion dollar Giga factory will
solve a problem that the power industry
has so far failed at to create a
cost-effective battery to store
electricity on a massive scale it starts
with small backup systems for people
with rooftop solar great for those who
want to live entirely off the grid but
that's a tiny market for households
still connected to the grid the
batteries aren't yet cheap enough to
make economic sense there's a much
bigger market Tesla is going after
businesses and utilities here's why in
the next five years solar power will
make up more than 50 percent of
California's electricity during the
sunniest part of the day and then
provide no power at night batteries
could help even out the power supply by
storing electricity from off-peak hours
to be used during peak demand hours
shifting the peak would cut utility
bills for businesses like Walmart which
are already testing the new systems some
utilities are also eager to build
battery storage power companies must
maintain so-called peaker plants
expensive facilities that sit idle for
most of the year but are needed when
electricity demand is greatest batteries
could replace some peaker plants while
strengthening the grid the cost of
batteries is falling as fast as the cost
of solar panels very fast
the tiny new energy storage industry is
about to break open and whether it's
from Tesla or one of its many emerging
competitors some electricity from your
outlet may soon be coming from a better
you